l'opération est délicate
allongé sur des civières c'est malades
sont transbordés sur un bateau c'est le
seul moyen de quitter la ville
face à l'avancée des Ukrainiens les rues
sont demandées aussi villes d'évacuer
airsson il laisse derrière eux une ville
en proie au bombardement
c'est la traversée de tous les dangers à
bord les visages sont fermés peur d'être
touché par un tir
sur l'autre rive elle est plus éloignée
du front les ferry se succèdent avec à
leur bord des centaines de passagers
ils ont emporté ce qu'il pouvait
sentiment de soulagement à l'arrivée
avec parfois la dure prise de conscience
d'avoir tout perdu la voiture toutes les
affaires d'une ville ne reste plus rien
elle et sa famille en sont convaincus
pour eux c'est un voyage sans retour qui
commence la maison où ils sont passés
leur vie a été bombardé
si on a plus de maison rentrer ou notre
maison a complètement brûlé rentrer où
on ne sait plus de qui avoir peur on a
été sous la menace depuis 7 mois déjà où
il tire
ceux qui ne savent pas où aller sont
pris en charge par les Russes il
contrôle la zone tous sont citoyen
ukrainien mais c'est bien vers la Russie
qu'ils sont envoyés
bien sûr ma patrie c'est l'Ukraine mais
ce départ est temporaire
mais la majorité de ce qui partent nous
disent soutenir les Russes
tous les habitants à qui nous avons
parlé nous ont dit qu'il n'avaient pas
été forcé par l'armée russe à quitter
airsson ils nous ont même dit qu'il y
avait des habitants qui voulaient rester
coûte que coûte dans la ville